hey guys don't worry i know things have
seemed pretty bad in the past few weeks
and months what with the record
inflation the four dollar and five
dollar per gallon gasoline averages and
the prospect of nuclear holocaust but
have no fear
rest assured vice president kamala
harris has the answer
imagine a future
the freight trucks that deliver bread
and milk to our grocery store shelves
and the buses that take children to
school and parents to work imagine all
the heavy-duty vehicles that keep our
supply lines strong and allow our
economy to grow imagine
that they produced zero emissions
well you all imagined it
that's why we're here today
because we have the ability to see what
can be
unburdened by what has been
and then to make the possible
actually happen
imagine all the people
for today
excuse me excuse me
i was just trying to uh to put myself in
an estate in which i could understand
what kamala harris said
from what i can tell she is saying that
we're going to have a fast-moving supply
chain someday
and the way we're going to get it is by
completely getting rid of all our
transportation infrastructure and
replacing it with uh
well that part can be worked out later
maybe drum circles it's not going to be
windmills it's not going to be solar
those barely produce any energy they're
extremely inefficient it's not going to
be nuclear that is extremely efficient
and it produces a lot of energy and we
know how to do it but
we're not going to do it for some reason
that kamala harris can't quite explain
and it's certainly not going to be oil
and gas which are relatively very
efficient and abundant and we were just
producing a lot of it a few years ago
but no more in the meantime
we're going to pay record prices for gas
with dollars that are worth nothing
thanks to the policies of a president
who sounds like lenin both john and
vladimir and vice president yoko ono
on the bright side
we may still get our free crack pipes so
at least there's a chance we can
understand what in the hell it is that
they think they're doing i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from maximilian mk
gill who says it's amazing how patriotic
the democrats can be when it's not their
country that's true
they are true ukrainian patriots
they are they're chinese patriots
sometimes but they just never seem to be
american patriots isn't that isn't that
too bad because we want to protect
ourselves we want to protect our
national identity we want to protect our
personal identity which is why you got
to check out lifelock right now head on
over to lifelock.com
knowles if kovid was not bad enough now
we all need to be on the lookout for
fake unregulated pop-up covid testing
sites identity thieves have been using
these to harvest personal information
without any intent of providing covid
test results remember you should never
pay or give out your social security
number to receive a covid test it's
important to understand how cyber crime
and identity theft are affecting our
lives every day we put our information
at risk on the internet in an instant a
cyber criminal could steal what's yours
sometimes even harm your finances your
credit your good reputation good thing
there's lifelock lifelock helps detect a
wide range of identity threats such as
your social security number for sale on
the dark web
you have access to a dedicated
restoration specialist if you become a
victim no one can prevent all identity
theft or monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can help protect
what's yours with lifelock by norton
join right now save up to 25 off your
first year lifelock.com knowles that is
lifelock.com knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s
for 25 off you know kamala harris isn't
even the worst one that's the crazy part
kamala harris who doesn't make any sense
who sounds like she just ripped a bong
in freshman philosophy class to to solve
the energy crisis you know man just
imagine man
what if the color that i think is green
you think is blue you know man just
imagine and that's the way it is
somehow
she is still more likable than a number
of people in the biden administration
top of that list top of the unlikable i
just i can't deal with it list in the
biden administration
top of the
vapid platitude
give me a freaking break list in the
biden administration
it's transportation secretary pete
butterjudge who recently
tried to sort of twist himself into a
logical pretzel to explain how what he
does at the transportation department
is intrinsically tied up with civil
rights
now some are asking what transportation
could possibly have to do with racial
justice
some have been asking that very
pointedly
so it's all the more fitting that we're
here at this bridge
this piece of infrastructure that became
a battleground in the struggle for equal
rights
this place that reminds us how
transportation and civil rights have
always
always been related
from the ships that carried so many into
bondage to the fairies and wagons of the
underground railroad that transported so
many to freedom
from the train car at issue in plessy
versus ferguson to the bus where rosa
parks decided to keep her seat
we are reminded again and again how deep
is that relationship between the
physical movement of human beings
and the social movement to change this
country
shut up
shut up pete buddha judge you uh oh i
just he just drives me
crazy
he's just
that teacher's pet
trying way too hard just oh actually um
when you really think about it i'm sort
of like martin luther king um i pete
buddha judge the mayor of south bend and
now the head of a a minor cabinet
department i'm i'm pretty much
i'm pretty much frederick douglass
actually when you um in this paper i
will describe how it's just shut up no
you're not you run
you run a department of the government
that is supposed to keep stuff moving on
the roads and you're failing at that by
the way probably the biggest well until
a week or two ago until the gas prices
went through the roof and inflation hit
a 40-year high
you
were failing more than anyone else in
the government because the biggest
problem in the country was the supply
chain issue so you you're not doing that
you're you're the ports are backed up as
can be the supply chain isn't really
working so that's fine you're an
incompetent government employee there
are plenty of those but now you're
comparing yourself to rosa parks
he is trying so hard to make
transportation secretary a stepping
stone to president it is not
it is not that
pete bootage edge good
grief it's so
it's not gonna happen it's like fetch
it's like fetch in mean girls it's stop
trying to make
the transportation secretary thing
happen booty judge that is not a
stepping stone to president i know look
right now the biden administration is so
deeply unpopular biden's approvals in
the 30s kamala's in the 20s pizza's in
the 30s so relatively it's fairly strong
compared to the others but it's just not
going to happen bro this is
calm down cool with the ambition here
it's a complete
disaster and by the way the
transportation secretary like doesn't
matter that much so he can go off and
make his stupid speeches and it's
it doesn't really matter
but the rest of the biden cabinet
secretaries are a disaster too notably
the secretary of state anthony blinken
who
cannot give a straight answer on what
exactly we're seeing go on in ukraine
the international criminal court is
opening an investigation into russian
war crimes the u.s embassy said it's a
war crime to attack a nuclear power
plant uh they tweeted that out the u.s
embassy in keith but then the state
department told other
uh embassies around the world to not
retweet it
which is a confusing step has the u.s
seen evidence that russia is committing
war crimes or not
uh jake we've seen very credible reports
of um deliberate attacks on civilians
which would constitute a war crime uh
we've seen very uh credible reports
about the the use of certain weapons
and what we're doing right now is
documenting all of this uh putting it
all together uh looking at it and making
sure that uh as
people and the appropriate
organizations and institutions
investigate whether war crimes have been
or are being committed
that
we can support whatever whatever they're
doing so
right now we're looking at these reports
they're very credible
and we're documenting everything
so putin right now is committing war
crimes in ukraine
putin is hitler right that's what we've
heard from the liberal establishment
putin is hitler history has returned
again he's invading his neighbor he's
going to invade the rest of these
countries and we've got to stop him
because he's hitler and he's committing
war crimes but also we shouldn't do
anything
this has been the central problem for
the administration and the entire
liberal establishment with this with
this putin war in ukraine they can't
decide what it is is he hitler if he's
hitler i guess we better use the
military to stop him right because he's
hitler well no he's he's hitler for the
purposes of
pushing through some sanctions but he's
not he's not hitler he's not a big
threat and he's committing war crimes
but we're not going to really pursue the
war crimes and what
what is it the administration is just
vacillating because they don't want to
make any of the hard choices
they don't they don't want to go to war
the american people i don't think want
to go to war over ukraine
and so they they just go back and forth
we're going to take the sanctions off
russia we're going to put more sanctions
on russia you go back and forth and back
and forth but if you stand in the middle
of the road you're going to get hit by a
truck sometimes the wrong decision is
actually better than indecision
sometimes the wrong decision can at
least clarify the situation but if you
just keep going back and forth yes we
have clear evidence he's committing war
crimes but we're not going to do
anything we're just going to keep
committing evidence
collecting evidence he's committing war
crimes dude maybe we should do something
about unless you don't really believe
that
unless
you're just stuck unless this
administration is just stuck they've got
no answers for anything kamala harris
gets asked what are you going to do
about this very acute particular energy
crisis and she says just imagine you
know just imagine and close your eyes
and imagine and that's what's going to
happen
what do you talk daydreams are not
national policy darling you need to
you need to do stuff hey guys
transportation i'm basically like rosa
parks okay rosa fix the roads then
hey martin how about you get the trucks
moving again and get the ports emptied
out so we get our consumer goods they
can't do it it's all this pie in the sky
rhetoric about how wonderful and great
they all are but they're not willing to
actually do anything in practice now
when you need to do stuff specifically
to your car i strongly recommend you
check out rock auto right now head on
over to rockauto.com fill in knowles in
the how did you hear about us box why
would you spend
30 percent more
50 percent more 100 percent more
for the same
auto parts at the brick and mortar store
when you could just go to rockauto.com
rockauto.com has a super easy to
navigate website so simple even i can do
it it's a family business been serving
auto parts customers online for 20 years
saves you all that time you don't need
to drive to the store then you get out
then they pepper you with questions then
they go in the back to get the part they
don't have the part there's just too
many makes and models these days they
have to order it in you have to wait
it's all that time don't do it go to
rockauto.com no gimmicks no special save
28
at 2 a.m uh no it's just always reliably
low prices the same prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers
rockauto.com head on over there right
now see all the parts available for your
car or truck and then most importantly
write knowles k-n-w-l-e-s
in their how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you
the
one change that we've seen now with
regard to this war in ukraine in terms
of u.s policy is the united states which
has said we're not getting involved we
don't we don't want a no-fly zone we
don't we're not going to take on
russia's military they did however just
agree to send nato fighter planes
to ukraine what more can the united
states do here if for instance the
polish government a nato member wants to
send fighter jets does that get a green
light from the u.s are you afraid that
that will escalate tension
no that that that gets a green light in
fact we're talking uh with uh our polish
friends right now
about what we might be able to do to
backfill uh their needs if in fact they
choose to provide these fighter jets to
to the ukrainians
so hold on we're not gonna go to war
we're not going to
send our planes over there but we're
going to have the poles send their
planes and then we're going to backfill
the polish planes
so effectively we are sending our our
jets there
we're just doing it in a really
inefficient way
we're having the polls send the jets and
then we're giving the polls some jets
again and again they want to have their
cake and eat it too they want to be too
clever by half while too clever by half
got us into this situation
in the first place what do the american
people want according to a one poll from
reuters almost three-quarters of
americans
want a no-fly zone in russia but i don't
believe that for one second i think it's
the same exact problem that the biden
administration has
which is we like the idea of a no-fly
zone oh good that's yeah get those those
russian airplanes out of the sky yeah
let's have a no-fly zone because it's
bad that people are being hurt right now
so let's stop the people from being hurt
no fly zone and okay we're good
i don't think most people know what a
no-fly zone is
no-fly zone is you're at war a no-fly
zone is
russia sends their airplanes up in the
sky and we shoot those airplanes out of
the sky so we are directly firing upon a
nuclear former superpower we somehow
managed to get through the entire cold
war basically without any direct action
between americans and russians no direct
action that people acknowledged for a
very long time and now we're just going
to shoot them out of the sky
over a
centuries-long territorial dispute with
ukraine doesn't seem like
the best idea in the world rubio made
this point too rubio said a no-fly zone
means war do you want to go to war do
you want to go to world war iii i don't
i don't think so
and i think zielinski the head of
ukraine has sort of given up on this
actually you know how much i hate to say
i told you so you know it pains me to do
it but i've got to do it unfortunately
because i keep getting proved right on
all of these things so i have said for
weeks now i said joe biden caused this
war yes putin is the aggressor yes putin
is morally responsible for the invasion
but putin has wanted to invade ukraine
for a very long time the reason he's
doing it now is because of very specific
actions that joe biden took and some
that he didn't take actually with regard
to sanctions and i said this and i got a
lot of criticism for it
i said look this is just true what is
happening right now is playing out
because of joe biden well you know who
agrees with me
the lib's hero mr zielinski velodimore
zielinski the the
leader of ukraine he's he just told
senators in the united states that if
the us had started sanctions months ago
as conservatives wanted as ted cruz was
pushing there would not have been war he
says you tell me 100 that there will be
war in a few days time what are you
waiting for we will not need your
sanctions after there's a bombardment or
after our state is shot at
or if we have no more borders we do not
have an economy or parts of our state
are occupied
this is exactly
what we had been saying
joe biden is the one in charge of the
sanctions
and the democrats run the entire
government at this point
you had bipartisan support for sanctions
on the nordstrom 2 russian oil pipeline
before biden gets into office biden
makes it a big push to get rid of those
sanctions and what happens he invades
ukraine i hate how right
i am now
look putin has
faced some pushback from the fighting
among from the ukrainians against the
russian forces he's faced some pushback
from the international community from
nation states and from corporations
but now i think he's just finished now
he's done
putin putin's over
and you'll you'll know why he's over if
you watched the 2022 independent spirit
awards
a couple of nights ago where nick
offerman
and megan mullally
okay you remember nick offerman was the
guy from parks and rec
and megan mullally was the
saucy lady on will and grace they
they told putin
to f off
done over no more war the war is over
now they said quote i think we speak for
everyone here
when we say we were hoping for a quick
and peaceful resolution
specifically f off and go home putin
eff off putin they said they were going
to send putin off with a spirit awards
salute and then mulally and her husband
held up their middle fingers to the
camera that'll do it
oh man i bet putin
hasn't recovered from that it's been two
days
that's right you go girl you tell him
you know well-behaved women
seldom make history okay
that'll do it a bunch of liberal actors
whining in a room that's going to stop
it
frankly it's about as effective as the
biden administration's policy has been
it's just people trying to make
themselves feel better but without
wanting to do anything that involves
cost
okay i'm going to change my facebook
profile picture now it's going to be
blue and yellow that'll show putin
yeah i'm going to put the ukrainian flag
in my twitter handle yeah
that'll show putin
hey i'm gonna
tell putin to f off yeah that'll no do
you know do you know what would have
showed him
uh if we had uh killed the oil pipeline
before he invaded that would have showed
him or if and i'm not advocating this if
we had sent troops in that would have
showed him
or if we had taken a harder line on him
for the entire biden administration that
would have shown him
f off change your facebook profile
picture
that doesn't show him that doesn't show
him anything it tries to make
you feel better about the fact that
we're not really doing anything in
ukraine
well-behaved women seldom make history
do you know today is international
women's day and i j i was thinking about
that phrase which is so
common now we hear this all the time we
hear this you know when trump called
hillary clinton a nasty woman during the
the 2016 presidential election then all
of these feminist ladies they said yeah
i'm nasty yeah i'm a disgusting filthy
nasty woman yeah that's girl power
well-behaved women seldom make history
so i thought about that phrase
you know it's not true
actually the women who make history
are
usually pretty well behaved i'm thinking
in no particular order
queen victoria margaret thatcher
sandra day o'connor
mother teresa
the virgin mary that would be the
clearest example
florence nightingale
uh just on and on and on and on
queen elizabeth ii she's the most
well-behaved woman in in history
probably and one of the most important
historical figures alive today
the will it's you know
someone said in response what about
hillary clinton oh you're talking about
the first female pro
right oops that's right
yeah but what about you know all those
feminists from the 70s who you know what
about jane fonda or something oh yeah
really
yeah queen victoria jane fonda i don't i
think one was probably
more significant to history than the
other
so happy international women's day uh be
a well-behaved one if you are a woman be
a well-behaved woman you have a better
chance of making history do not be a
nasty woman no one wants to to see a
nasty woman
now
speaking of men and women and all sorts
of strange sexual ideologies
this
might be the story on which i have been
proven right
the fastest ever this shocked even me
yesterday on the show
i mentioned
that a lot of people think look with
this lgbt ideology now people think not
everything has to be gay and i said
everything does have to be gay because
the left's ideology is one of radical
liberation and that they've liberated
themselves from traditions and from
bonds of community and now we're
liberating ourselves from nature itself
so men can be women and vice versa
everything does in fact have to be gay
and the florida senate democrats
marching through a building
proved me right
[Music]
the florida senate democrats now the
only thing that they can utter their
most cogent political argument is
gay gay gay gay gay gay gay gay gay gay
gay gay gay
the florida senate democrats said we've
just got one thing to say and you're
right you do that's the only thing you
have to say gay gay gay gay gay gay
that's all you've got
what else are you going to say
that's the that's the the final step in
the emancipation and liberation from all
the constrictions of
our society is to emancipate yourself
from nature so even beyond gay it's sort
of sort of like how alex jones talked
about how they turn the frickin frogs
gay but they actually turn the frogs
trans that's what the studies showed the
frogs were hermaphrodites really the
final step in the lgbt ideology is the t
is emancipating yourself from nature
itself proven i hate you know i hate to
say it it kills me to do it proven right
within 24 hours that's not bad now
i have to tell you since i've got a
pretty good record this week you cannot
miss our movie the hyperions it's
premiering this thursday night march
10th
we can't wait to share it with you it's
exactly what entertainment and hollywood
is missing these days it's not woke it
has zero underlying political message
it's just fun because when it comes to
entertainment that is what really
matters check out the trailer
[Music]
my name is vista mandelbaum
my brother and i have taken four
hostages everybody against the wall
we've come for one thing
our titan badges
is this real yes ma'am this is real
well i want that too it's the police
they want to talk to whoever's in charge
[Music]
this titan badge can grant an individual
superhuman power
perhaps it's time for someone else to
take on the responsibility
meet apollo
i'd recommend next time using your power
yeah i mean yeah if you think so
calling all
hyperions on my way
you're making such a mess in here
we've got a hyperion in roots not a good
time to look stupid
shots fired
god come on give me my gun
suit up for adventure
she's trying to destroy me
next question how's the family the
family is um
oh
gosh what is it
marvelous
[Music]
we're going to be streaming the movie
once on march 10th for all of youtube to
see this will be the last time that we
will premiere a movie on youtube so be
sure to head on over to the daily wire
youtube channel set a reminder for the
live showing after that you've got to be
a member to get in on the action so head
on over to dailywire.com subscribe so
you don't miss any more of the growing
cache of content we have to offer we'll
be right back with a lot more
great news out of texas speaking of the
t in lgbt america's largest pediatric
hospital is going to stop transiting the
kids
so previously this pediatric hospital
this is the texas children's hospital
was transiting the kids and chopping
them up and putting them on all sorts of
creepy chemicals and it's just it was
horrible and a horrible abuse of
children and then texas governor greg
abbott uh came in there and he said uh
no we're we're gonna classify transiting
the kids as child abuse which it
obviously is and so you got to stop
doing it and then this hospital said
the mission of texas children's hospital
is to create a healthier future for all
children including transgender children
within the bounds of the law this step
was taken to safeguard our health care
professionals and impacted families from
potential criminal legal ramifications
love this this is a great example of
culture being downstream of politics
i frankly don't think that the
distinction between culture and politics
is all that clear but you know there's
this famous line from andrew breitbart
politics is downstream of culture and
obviously there's some truth to this
because the movies and the media and and
rituals and behaviors that are not
necessarily associated with the
government can shape our political order
but it is also true that laws will shape
our culture
when you outlaw something generally
speaking you get less of it you
discourage it when you subsidize
something generally speaking you get
more of it when you
create other incentives for certain
behaviors
such as the promotion of radical sexual
ideologies in the law then you get more
of them and when you ban abusive
surgeries like transiting the kids you
get less of it this is great stuff i'm
very glad the hospital stopped it very
glad that the texas governor pushed it
this way
you're seeing a
proliferation of radical ideology
throughout non-governmental institutions
so in this hospital this hospital's
transiting the kids that is a radical
ideology that's being pushed not exactly
by the government right the hospital
has some connection to the government
but it's also sort of private
and it was pushing this ideology
pizza hut is pushing another radical
ideology pizza hut
through the pizza hut foundation
is pushing critical race theory
they are presenting training pamphlets
for teachers that make statements such
as quote racism exists within and beyond
schools and communities of learning
the myth of a racial hierarchy remains a
dominant part of america's culture acts
of violence against black communities
are often identified on social media by
the hashtag black lives matter you know
all of these
you know this epidemic black men can't
even walk out their doors without being
hunted down says lebron james
pizza hut this pizza hut is pushing this
crap
pizza the silence of little caesars is
deafening like when will literal caesars
speak up against racism or whatever
pizza why is pizza hut doing this well
because pizza hut has this non-profit
foundation a non-governmental nonprofit
foundation which is pushing
this radicalism
we don't have a vote in what pizza hut
does
right pizza hut is not
a democratic institution
and it's not exactly affiliated with the
government but this is how the liberal
establishment rules they rule through a
series of ngos and non-profit groups
that push their crap that are basically
insulated from the political process for
now and they should not be we should we
should
use the political process
to bring them into line
i don't care
if
it is the government
destroying my way of life and completely
upending america's society or if it's
some corporation
okay i don't if if someone is treading
on me to give the image of the gadsden
flag it doesn't make me feel any better
if the organization that is treading on
me is google okay it doesn't make me
feel any better if it's facebook taking
away my rights and my liberties and my
way of life
rather than the government say
we've got to get better about this as
conservatives we've for a couple of
decades fell into this very stupid idea
of well you know google's a private
company they have the right to do
whatever they want twitter build your
own twitter right as though that has
ever worked
if you go back
to the early days of the modern
conservative movement frankly if you go
back to some of the most libertarian
figures
in the conservative movement
they were advocating
not just focusing on the government and
letting quote-unquote private industry
do whatever they want
they were advocating bringing private
enterprise
into
line as well
barry goldwater
as
for mr conservative at the early days
the conservative movement and also
extremely libertarian in that early
alliance between the libertarians and
the traditional conservatives barry
goldwater wrote in conscience of a
conservative quote
let us henceforth make war on all
monopolies whether corporate or union
the enemy of freedom is unrestrained
power and the champions of freedom will
fight against the concentration of power
wherever they find it
yeah man that's good stuff
that's clear thinking
of course
we're not going to just let
random ngos and very powerful
corporations completely upend our
society
and just throw our hands in the air and
say well they're private industry well
their private organizations know we're
going to fight back and we're going to
use the political order to do it in a
way that is just and fair but we've got
to fight back speaking of powerful
non-governmental organizations
guess who's back in town
the clinton global initiative you
remember that the clinton global
initiative was a slush fund
for the clinton family to collect money
from all sorts of shady figures overseas
and spend it as they see fit on the
global initiative and it was
so crooked
it was so obviously crooked that hillary
shut it down in 2016 because it looked
like such a clear conflict of interest
that
they couldn't keep it running
one of the curious facts about the
clinton global initiative is that the
number one donor to the clinton global
initiative was
ukraine i'm not saying it was the
government of ukraine i'm saying it was
ukrainians
ukrainians who had a lot of money
they gave a lot of money to the clintons
and
and that was that they probably didn't
want anything in return this was in no
way a quid pro quo they're just really
generous and they really for some reason
like the clintons and they gave her a
lot of money
now why why did people really give to
the clinton global initiative and the
clinton foundation for that matter they
gave to it because
they believed that hillary clinton was
going to be the president and so
they wanted to curry favor and they did
that by just buying them outright and
then in 2016 it looked so bad that
they shut it down
so what does it mean
that they're opening it up again well
one
it's pretty interesting that the clinton
global initiative that had such a
connection to ukraine is relaunching now
at this moment of peril for ukraine it's
just a strange coincidence
but but two and this is more important i
think what this means
is not necessarily that hillary clinton
is running for president in 2024
but it means that the clintons believe
that people think hillary is running for
president in 2024
the only reason that the clinton global
initiative ever got money is because
foreigners believed that hillary clinton
was going to be the president
okay
people even americans believed she was
going to be the president so they were
purchasing favor
now it may well be the case that
hillary's not going to run and she's
just reopening this thing to make a
little bit of money
but the only way that it could make
money is if people think she's running
so at the very least the clintons are
creating the impression
that she will be running in 2024 and she
probably should
kamala harris is a joke she's almost
certainly going nowhere
you know
uh well-behaved women never make history
what's the line from kamala she she
tried to make this line her sort of
catchphrase she said i'm not finished
i'm not finished remember she was in
that debate with mike pence excuse me
i'm not finished at well i think 27
approval rating i think you might be
finished i think
you're finished so she's probably out
joe biden doesn't know what day it is
and pete buddha judge is a joke and he's
probably the most attractive of the
people in the biden administration so it
does leave an opening for hillary
hillary's still extremely unlikable but
compared to the presidents we elect
these days she's she's a spring chicken
she's pretty young
and now she's raising some money
and we'll see where it goes
speaking of guys running for president
one of the people who's making taking
the clearest steps to run is florida
governor ron desantis
ron desantis just had this bill which
was going to kick
crazy sexual theories out of elementary
schools that's why those florida senate
democrats were chanting through the
hallways
ron desantis
was just asked about this bill he gave
what i thought was a pitch perfect
answer
in education what critics call the don't
say gay bill is on the senate does it
say that in the bill
does it say that in the bill
i'm asking you to tell me what's in the
bill because you are pushing false
narratives it doesn't matter what
critics say it says it bans classroom
instruction on sexual identity and
gender orientation for who
for for grades pre-k through three
six-year-old seven-year-olds and um the
idea that you wouldn't be honest about
that and tell people what it actually
says it's why people don't trust people
like you because you peddle false
narratives and so we disabuse you of
those narratives
and we're going to make sure that
parents are able to send their kid to
kindergarten without having some of this
stuff injected into their school
curriculum
i love that answer you immediately put
it back on the media which is
does it say that in the bill what does
it say in the bill and and this reporter
used one of the cheapest tricks in the
book said some critics are saying that
it's a it's a don't say gay pill some
critics oh who are the critics name me
the critics some people say no you're
the critic you're the one saying so okay
you defend your proposition then
where does it say that in the bill oh it
doesn't well in the bill it says you
can't talk about
sexual identity and weird creepy sex
behavior right for five-year-olds you
creep
five-year-olds yeah five-year-olds
shouldn't be learning about all the
decadent
debauched
deviant sexual desires that people like
you in the media have in your head
yeah obviously and so to say the reason
i bring this up though is desantis is
getting better at this
he was already pretty good but he's
getting much better he's obviously
running for president and he's
he's running on cultural issues he's not
running away from cultural issues he's
running on them
we're and specifically on education
which is a smart bet because that's what
got
glenn younkin elected in virginia this
is this education issue is something
that can really
spread across partisan lines it can get
some liberals it can get some
independence people who don't want their
kids being taught creepy radical
ideologies on race and sex now on the
other side of that
you've got the
allegedly republican governor of utah
spencer cox who has just vowed to veto
a
sports bill that would keep men out of
the women's league so he's going to veto
a bill that would point out that
transgenderism is completely kooky and
we're not going to we're going to allow
women to have their own sports leagues
house bill 11 would require student
athletes participate in sports based on
their sex
not based on their delusions
and
it passed this past the utah senate on
friday passed the state legislature on
in february
and
this quote-unquote republican governor
of utah spencer cox said i just want
them to know that it's going to be okay
talking about transgender students we're
going to work through this
and he's vowing to veto the bill
with republicans like this
who needs democrats
i don't know now look spencer cox he
might cut taxes great that's cool i'm
glad he's cutting taxes he might
deregulate some industry okay fine
whatever
if if you
don't understand this issue if you don't
if you are unwilling to stand up for the
fact that men and women are different
and you're if you're unwilling to make
that claim in public life you are
completely useless you're worse than
useless you should be kicked out of the
republican party i don't care elect a
democrat at that point i don't i guess
my taxes will go up a little bit
but this is so fundamental
and i suspect look either this guy's
just an idiot who doesn't realize that
men and women are different
or he's a coward and he believes that
well the social issues aren't going to
play very well and
never mind that utah is basically the
most conservative state in the entire
country
no i gotta back away from the social
issues buddy buddy
you're living in the 90s you're living
in the early 2000s you're forgetting
that right now the social issues are
winners
for conservatives never mind that it's
true never mind that it's the right
thing to do to keep men out of the
women's locker rooms
talk about calling someone a
conservative you can't even conserve the
women's bathroom the women's locker room
but it's also
a political winner
for
conservatives
speaking of romance speaking of men and
women
i got to get to a story that i care
about an unreasonable amount
it's the love triangle between
kanye
and kim kardashian
and pete skeet davidson
kanye and kim kardashian
were married
they have four children together
then
kim
wanted to dissolve the marriage kanye
didn't want to dissolve the marriage
kim started dating this guy this not
very good-looking guy from saturday
night live who somehow has dated all of
the hottest women in the world and kanye
is in trouble now because he made a
music video in which he
would appear to be attacking physically
attacking pete davidson
the cameras watch the kids i stopped
taking the credit custodian i bought the
house next door what you think the point
of really being rich for when you give
them everything they only want more
[Music]
this ain't your mama house climb on your
brother's shoulders get that top ramen
out god send me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis
so you get the idea goes on and on and
he's got this little claymation figure
of of the man who took his wife from him
and he's you know sort of attacking the
little the little figure so kanye is in
hot water here they say this is wrong
you shouldn't threaten this man it's
terrible this is awful stuff and kanye
for his part he said look art is simply
therapy
just like this view art is protected as
freedom of speech art inspires and
simplifies the world art is not a proxy
for any ill or harm so he's saying look
this is just art
okay i'm making art i'm not this is not
a direct threat i'm not going to go kill
pete davidson even though i said that
god saved me from the crash just so i
could beat pete davidson's
derriere
i i don't i don't really mean it it's
just art
and now
a lot of libs are rallying to pete
davidson's
side james gunn
who is that uh
fairly creepy film director he he said
quote for the record pete davidson is
one of the nicest sweetest guys i know a
truly generous tender and funny spirit
and he treats everyone around him with
respect
he stole a dude's wife he stole a dude's
wife with whom that dude has four
children
that's not very nice
that's not generous that's not
respectful that's not the right thing to
do
kim and kanye i don't even think they're
divorced yet and he's stole this man's
wife as this man is trying to put his
family back together that's not a good
thing to do this is why i care about the
story so much
i i know i shouldn't hear that much
about
kanye and kim kardashian but i do i do
because
it's just wrong you've got this
situation where
you've got a reality tv star and she's
married to this sort of pop culture
genius who is i believe bipolar he's got
some psychological struggles that he
deals with
and but he's he also
converted to christianity he also is
just somewhat more conservative than
most people in his industry so a lot of
the things that kanye will say and do
that people call totally crazy
are actually just
normal behavior for a lot of americans
like when he said hey i like what
trump's doing i like i you know he puts
the mag hat on they say he's gone crazy
he's lost his mind uh you know half the
country
supported the maga hat buddy it's not
that's not evidence that you're
schizophrenic or something like that
okay it's just that the left
pathologizes any behavior that is in any
way conservative they've been doing this
for years lionel trilling once said many
decades ago that conservatism is nothing
more than a series of irritable mental
gestures okay so that's but but sure
kanye's got some problems he's got some
mental
sicknesses
what happened to
i kim
take thee kanye for my husband to have
and to hold in good times and bad and
sickness and in health unless that
sickness is a mental sickness in which
case see ya later buddy sayonara sucker
i'm gonna go hang with the child from
saturday night live no
no man that's not how you do it
and the reason the reason this story
really strikes home for me is we've got
plummeting marriage rates marriage as an
institution is collapsing we even
redefine marriage at this level of the
supreme court and that's not good a
society cannot survive without
a sensible definition of the family and
a strong family it can't do it the
family is the bedrock political
institution
and it's just so sick to see a man steal
this dude's wife and then the dude is
trying to get his wife back because
they've got four children together and
then the woman what did she say she said
she actually had a big spread in a
vogue or some popular magazine where she
said my 40s are about me i don't care
what other people want i'm just gonna do
what makes me feel good oh yeah that's
brave that's courageous scar your four
children that's a good idea keep your
four kids away from their daddy so that
you can
pursue your own interests yeah you know
well-behaved women seldom make history
how about you just do your duty how
about you just suck it up and yes your
husband is eccentric
and maybe you're more attracted to the
the dirty looking guy from saturday
night live but tough tough it out man
you know it's not all about you good
grief good grief speaking of the family
more good news out of florida
florida has just passed a 15-week
abortion ban
the measure prohibits women from
receiving abortions after 15 weeks of
pregnancy it provides no exceptions
you know 15 weeks sorry that's that
i guess it does provide an exception if
the mother's life is in danger but it
doesn't provide
exceptions you know if the mother just
says well you know my
mental health is in danger well my
career is in danger no for that that's
not going to work you're not allowed to
kill babies for that the reason that
this law is passing now is in
preparation for the dobbs case dobbs
versus jackson women's health
organization this is the case that could
overrule roe versus wade and planned
parenthood b casey
uh this is the same sort of bill that
brought that case in the first place i
think it's more evidence that the
republicans believe
that
the
court very likely could
overrule this but more importantly
it's evidence that the republicans know
that pro-life
is a winner
that the social issues are winners for
them
and this should be a warning to any
republican lawmakers or candidates who
are listening to this show right now
you've had a couple examples of people a
few examples now of of conservatives
running away from the so-called social
issues asa hutchinson in arkansas
wouldn't sign on to a bill
getting rid of transgenderism in sports
christie gnome in south dakota although
she ended up reversing course on that
this guy spencer cox in utah they're
just running away from it oh we don't
want the social the social issues
are winners okay the democrats have
nothing right now they've got no answers
to anything
they are all they can do is spit out
platitudes and weird rewrites of of john
lennon songs you know just imagine
imagine imagine man they're living in a
fantasy world a fantasy world where
babies are in babies and men are really
women and the that fantasy world does
not play well in peoria because in the
real world here things are not going
well as a result of those delusions run
on the reality republicans it will help
you i'm michael knowles as the michael
knowles show will see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less join me and
my co-host georgia hal for daily
coverage of all the biggest stories on
morning wire